well an editor starts on day two of
shooting sometimes you start a little
bit before in terms of discussing the
script but mostly I'm there to look at
the dailies the day after they shoot
things and work very closely with the
director to check that he's getting what
he wants and that everything is working
not just on a technical level but maybe
to do with performance and the structure
of the story and you know shooting is a
bit like a shopping expedition you're
trying to get everything crammed into
your trolley before you know the money
runs out and you start filming and you
have to kind of have your wits about you
to know that you've got everything you
need to be able to tell the story as
well as you can and then you're seeing
the raw state of the dailies and you're
the first person to see those which is a
great thrill or if you previous day was
a nightmare for everybody it could be
disastrous but that's that that's a very
exciting moment to the beginning of the
day so the assistants will go through
and they'll they'll take the the sound
of the picture sync them up and then
assemble the the raw dailies into a
fashion that the editor has dictated it
works for them the assistants prepare it
for me in a manner that is very
particular to me that they all know I'll
go through in a very methodical way and
review the footage and my goal it's to
inhabit that footage as deeply as I can
so that I can understand what the
director is going after I try not to
read the script too much because I don't
want to be influenced too much by the
script because sometimes they'll shoot
something that doesn't quite match what
the script is and you can try forever to
make it feel like it's matching the
script or you can look at the footage as
the footage itself there's actually an
old saying that you write one script you
shoot another and you edit another and
so I feel at the end of beating that I'm
at the end of that process I'm really
trying to tell a story in the way that
everyone wanted it to be told but in the
way that it's been told by the by
responding to the footage and not
responding to the original intention if
that makes sense as soon as I finish the
scene the first thing I do is I bring in
my assistants and ask them what they
think because it's really important to
me I just I'd like to have very very
smart people around me people who
challenge me and challenge my opinion
every director is different when
I work on the fast and furious movies
like Justin Lin doesn't like to sit
still for too long so he's like there
were two to three editors at all times
so that he can go in one room watch a
sequence give notes and then go in
another room watch a sequence and give
notes quentin is incredibly hands-on he
wants to be there for every part of the
process I did a cut of Django and
assembly while the movie was shooting
but when we came back in like that
assembly was really simply to
familiarize myself with the material and
and try some things that could be
interesting when when I did it with
Quentin like he really likes to go back
and start from scratch and then so I
build it all up then I show the director
and then the director sort of says right
you've done everything wrong and then
they build it all up that how they want
it and then the producers say that's not
working at all and then they build it
the way they want it and then the
writers come in and say well that's not
the original tension whatsoever so then
you rebuild it again and then it gets
back to basically what you did in the
first place people come in and it's
lovely that they have that objectivity
and it can be white actually quite magic
because you know the director will come
in and see something that they didn't
intend but it's something that they
really love that you've done and all of
a sudden they're like oh that's really
cool well why don't we try this and all
of a sudden you're off in a different
direction
it's an incredibly creative job so first
and foremost you've got to be very
responsive to not only you know picture
and editing and but sound and music and
performance and it covers you know your
in the still point of a turning world
there's many many things coming in from
you from all sorts of departments and
you know you're right in the middle with
the director and you have to kind of I
suppose you have to have good personal
skills in terms of working under great
pressure if there are fundamental
problems with a piece on a script level
those are that are pretty undeniable
those are always difficult to to sort of
reconcile and there are any number of
ways to try to deal with that
it depends on resources it depends on a
lot of different things personalities
sometimes if you're in a challenging
situation you know either
director-producer or if you're in
television a network executive maybe a
bit reactive those can be particularly
challenging situations it's interesting
sometimes I'll go for an interview and I
won't get the job and I don't mind if I
don't get the job because I'll meet the
editor that directors ended up working
with and realize that they the editor is
a very different person than me I can't
talk about sports to save my life and if
the director wants to talk about sports
as they're editing I'm not gonna be the
person they want to hang out with for 10
hours a day in a very small room in the
dark and I think that's okay and so I
think as an editor you've got to be
someone who is fun to be around or at
least good to talk to you and is a
creative collaborator but also someone
who it's kind of like a bartender or a
psychiatrist because at the end of the
day you're you know just sort of talking
to someone as you wipe the Barragan so
how was your day a good friend of mine
says you have to be a part of edit or
part therapist and I think there's a lot
of truth to that more is expected of the
editor we have had to become full-on
sound designers and oftentimes music
editors as well you know now that we're
editing in hi-def we can project that
and it looks pretty good when you were
working on a flatbed with film like it
wasn't even something that was possible
you would have to do a temp mix whenever
you were into a screening now I mean the
the the my tracks in the avid this is
what we screened when we put it in front
of an audience so I have to make sure
that the stuff sounds as good as it
possibly can you start off you're
walking into an empty room day one and
you don't have any pens or pencils or
equipment and invariably twelve months
later you need to have brought
everything in create something walk away
and then leave that room exactly as you
found it you know the other skills are
patience you know it's a long haul I
mean some people are on a film for a day
and others are on for a long time and
we're in the latter category I mean I
to save on 12 years I was on that for 11
months
you know without a break and often
without a weekend the most satisfying
moment is walking into a theater with an
audience who have not seen the movie
before and hopefully are going to engage
with it and sitting in the middle of a
theater like this with people around who
don't know that you've worked on the
film and seeing the feeling the audience
react around you to that that's the most
satisfying thing